Today we're going to discuss the puzzling case of Dan Cohen versus Kohl's media
company,
which deals with the question of when it is necessary for parties to intend that
an agreement with consideration the legally binding in order for them to be
legally bound by that agreement.
The setting for the case is the 1982 election for governor of the state of
Minnesota independent Republican candidate.
We lock Whitney was running against democratic farmer Labor candidate Rudy
Perpich,
who had served as governor for several years in the 1970s in the middle of the
election,
Dan Cohen,
who was a well known republican businessman called up reporters for two major
newspapers from the twin cities,
the St Paul Pioneer press dispatch,
and the Minneapolis Star Tribune.
He told them that he had information about a candidate in the election and
offered to give it to them if they agreed not to identify him in their reporting
or to ask him about his source.
That information turned out to be the records from cases that had been brought a
decade earlier against Marlene Johnson Purpitch his running mate.
When there reporters went to the courthouse to check the records were correct.
They discovered that column Cohen himself had sent someone to dig them up.
The editor's not the reporters,
but the editors at the newspapers decided that that this was an important part
of the story.
And the editors decided to include Cohen's identity in the articles in spite of
the reporters explicit promises.
And over there the reporters objections.
When Cohen's saw the newspapers the next day,
he was outraged to see his name in the articles.
He also lost his job because of these,
uh,
his name being mentioned.
And so we decided to take the newspaper publishers to court since the
information that had been published was true.
Uh,
he couldn't sue for defamation.
Instead,
he sued for fraudulent misrepresentation and for breach of contract at trial,
he won big.
The jury awarded him $200,000 in compensatory damages and a quarter of a million
dollars in punitive damages,
giving him the victory on both claims.
The court of appeals then reversed the misrepresentation claim.
We're going to read the Minnesota Supreme Court's decision from 1,990 which
ruled for the newspapers on both of these points
just as Symonette,
uh,
deals very quickly with the misrepresentation claims.
Uh,
he wrote a representation as to future acts does not support an action for fraud
merely because the represented act did not happen unless the promise or did not
intend to perform at the time the promise was made.
There was plenty of evidence that the reporters did intend to keep their sources
identity a secret when they made the promise.
One of them even refuse to have her name in the articles byline because she was
so offended by what her editors had done.
This misrepresentation rule means that mere failure to perform what one has
promised doesn't amount to fraud.
We don't want to characterize everyone who doesn't succeed at fulfilling all
their promises as a fraudster.
Instead,
when someone fails to follow through on a promise for which there was
consideration,
parties generally should pursue a suit for breach of contract.
We limit what is called promissory fraud actions to circumstances.
When the promissor at the time of promising didn't intend to perform.
The promise just disseminate then moves to the question of whether Cohen has a
valid claim for breach of contract.
On first glance,
his agreements with the reporters definitely look like contracts.
The reporter promises were given exchange for consideration in the form of the
documents that Cohen handed over.
There was consideration.
There was quid pro quo.
The newspapers then proceeded to break their promises about keeping his identity
secret,
but while Simondet certainly thinks that the reporters were ethically obliged
not to disclose Cohen's identity,
he's reluctant to make their agreements legally enforceable.
Moral and legal obligations do not always coincide.
Ultimately the judge is quote,
not persuaded that in the special milk idea of media news gathering a source and
a reporter ordinarily believe they are engaged in making a legally binding
contract.
They are not thinking in terms of offer and acceptance in any commercial or
business sense unquote and so the judge decides not to quote,
superimpose a legal obligation on a moral and ethical obligation unquote.
The case therefore suggests that at least in the context of reporters and their
sources,
there needs to be explicit evidence that the parties wanted to be legally bound
in order for their agreement to be legally binding.
I'm troubled by the justices conclusion that the sources don't think that
reporters are making legally binding commitments when they promised not to use
their name.
This rule is very odd because it's the opposite of the ordinary rule,
which is summarized in section 21 of the second restatement of contracts.
That section says neither real nor impairment intention that a promise be
legally binding is essential to the formation of a contract,
but a manifestation of intention that a promise shall not affect legal relations
may prevent the formation of a contract.
In other words,
the default is that when the parties make an agreement involving all of the
necessary components of offer and acceptance and consideration,
that agreement is legally binding.
Even if it doesn't say that the parties intend for it to be legally barred it
binding parties can choose explicitly not to make their agreements legally
binding,
but they need to go to extra effort to do so.
That's why you sometimes see the statement quote,
this is not a legally enforceable agreement included in written documents.
This is called a Tina Leah provision based on the abbreviation for this is not a
legally enforceable agreement.
In this case,
justice Symonette turns the principal on its head.
The parties don't have a legally binding contract because there's no explicit
evidence that they wanted that they intended it to be legally binding.
This is the general rule in many other countries including England and
continental Europe countries,
but not in the United States side from a few exceptions.
For example,
judge Simonett mentions that the rule that promises within families are
generally unenforceable without extra evidence that the family members intended
them to be legally bound.
Here the court seems to be motivated to make a new exception out,
uh,
out of the concern that legal liability in cases like these would interfere with
the important work of reporters.
And newspaper editors.
We saw a similar sort of concern for the effect of Law on particular professions
in Sullivan versus O'connor earlier when where the court was worried about
enforcing physicians promises of cures and that whether such enforcement would
interfere with the ability to to advise and a care for their patients.
It's not clear though that justice Symonette's concern about the news industry
industry is a valid one.
Sources might be more willing to give information to reporters if they knew that
the promises of confidentiality would be a legally enforceable.
It's also important to note that the United States Supreme Court ended up ruling
for the plaintiff in this case,
finding that generally applicable laws applied to the press in spite of the
incidental effects of the ability to gather and support the news.
The U S Supreme Court said that there still could be an action in a under
promissory Estoppel.
All right,
and so let's go to a quiz here in Eric agrees to give Maria one of his cats new
kittens if she helps him build a website at the time.
Neither of them thinks that a casual agreement between friends is legally
binding.
She helps him,
but he then refuses to give her the kitten.
Could Maria enforce the agreement in court?
Well,
the answer is yes.
As we've seen from the restatement,
the default rule in American law is it when parties come to an agreement with
consideration,
that agreement will be legally enforceable in court.
They can avoid the default only if they explicitly make their agreement non
enforceable with something such as a teen Aaliyah provision.
There are some exceptions to this rule.
The traditional ones are four agreements between family members and for social
engagements.
Your,
your friend can't take you to court if you show up late to lunch as you've seen
in the case of Cohen versus Kohl's media.
Uh,
courts occasionally find other exceptions as well.
Here,
judge justice seminar thought that confidentiality agreements between sources
and reporters were in a domain where parties would not expect legal consequences
to arise from their agreements.
And so he reversed the default rule.
Now,
the Supreme Court of the United States in New York Times versus Sullivan found
that under the first amendment of our Constitution,
uh,
a newspaper could not be liable for mere negligent misrepresentations concerning
public figures.
But imagine that a newspaper,
let's call it Savannah,
uh,
on the front page of each issue,
expressly promises to compensate any individual that it mentions who is injured
by the newspapers,
negligent misrepresentation,
and secondly expressly represents that it did.
Tends this promise to be legally enforceable.
The newspaper believes that it can sell more newspapers if it warrants the
quality of it's a product putting aside consideration problems.
Would it be constitutional to enforce this kind of contract?
In essence,
is New York Times versus Sullivan,
uh,
merely a default rule?
If so,
could the legislate your flip the default and require newspapers who didn't want
to stand behind the truthfulness of their statement to opt out of liability by
including a short disclaimer somewhere in the publication that they intend not
to be a responsible for the injury done by their negligent reporting.